argentina have won their first major
football trophy since 1993.
they've beaten defending champions
brazil one nil in the copper america
final
lionel messi holds it aloft argentina
copper america champions for the 15th
time
the wait is over angel di maria
scored the only goal of the game for
argentina in the 22nd minute
the win will also mean a 34 year old a
star player lionel messi
has finally won an international tr uh
trophy with this country
there was widespread criticism of the
decision to allow brazil to stage the
month-long event because of coronavirus
numbers
we'll go live to monica yanakir in
brazil's rio de janeiro in a moment
but first let's go live to daniel
schweinler in the argentine capital
buenos aires
daniel it's quite the party behind you i
almost feel bad about making you work
because this is probably going to be the
biggest party
uh that you're ever going to experience
probably for a while look at it
a big victory for not just argentina but
for lionel messi as well
[Music]
yeah i mean really it's over an hour and
a half since the final whistle blew
and thousands of people are still
arriving here in the center of buenos
aires
i suspect there will be similar seeds
across across argentina as well
um they've had to wait 28 years
for this tournament in the cup of
america there have been
four finals where they've lost uh
they've lost the world cup
this was probably leo messi's last
opportunity
to win a major tournament he did it
he lost in 2014 but i think
but yeah as you can see the party has
only just begun
uh argentina has been suffering like
many countries in the region
during the pandemic this is a lie some
light relief
very few people seem to be uh conforming
to the uh copyrighted 19 restrictions
but this is an opportunity obviously to
celebrate
to forget to forget those problems uh
and to take to the streets and celebrate
as i say this is gonna go for some time
leo messi and the argentine squad
will be celebrating in rio de janeiro um
we'll see where this takes us from here
it's our first victory in 28 years
thank you very much he's there in a sea
of blue and white but let's now
cross over to rio de janeiro where
monica yanakiv joins us
live monica you saw the celebrations
there in argentina
however not everybody is very happy that
this
tournament even took place because of
the pandemic
[Applause]
that's true well i'm standing in a bar
uh right next to the maracana stadium
some people here didn't even know that
this uh
the final game would be played today
this is because
uh well brazilians weren't very
interested in this cop america to begin
with
uh what made it worst was that it was a
sports event that turned into a
political discussion
because uh when president jair bolsonaro
decided to accept to host the
the tournament here just as brazil was
nearing
one a half a million dead by covid 19
and that brazil reached that landmark in
the midst of the pandemic so there was
widespread criticism
and even here there were people that
were cheering for messi
we did see the one people that got close
to the stadium were mostly their
argentines that were cheering not as
loudly
as in buenos aires with daniel
but we did see a couple here cheering as
well
so but brazilians say that a cop america
isn't that
important for them they're really
worried about what's gonna happen
in uh the world cup next year and uh
basically that's it here at the end of
the game in this bar that's
right behind me when the game ended
there some people
shouted okay it's a defeat for you
bolsonaro
out uh there's 63 percent of brazilians
now think he's incapable of
governing so this mixture of politics
and sports
did play a part in dampening the
enthusiasm
for the cup america here in brazil uh
but monica
one of the things that scientists have
said is that events like these are
super spreader events they are events
that will actually have a longer term
impact is that being discussed in brazil
yes well the scientists have been saying
they have been saying also that they
they're in favor of suspending
everything not just a cup america
but also uh the olympic games in japan
and uh also here at this moment in
brazil
uh there's there also have been played
games
uh that will decide uh their other games
are being played as well
they're against all these games so they
say uh
so what bolsonaro was saying is why is
everybody just
being against cop america just because i
decided you know that brazil could host
it
so so yes there is this discussion the
thing is that we were bringing in teams
that got infected as a matter of fact
in a very tragic moment it was 500
000 deaths that that happened exactly
when when this tournament was going on
in empty stadiums with no public
and brazilians here were watching on
television the european championship
with a lot more interest than coppa
america
monica yanakir there live for us in rio
de janeiro thank you very much